good evening from Chicago i'm laura
ingraham and welcome to the ingram angle
special Trump's week of battles
President Trump is a fighter there's no
doubt about that and it's a good thing
because he's facing attacks on multiple
fronts and in the next hour we're gonna
tell you how the media are putting
stories out some of them blatant lies to
undermine the president's agenda Alan
Dershowitz will be here to discuss
Trump's latest fight with the Justice
Department you won't believe what we're
learning about DOJ official Bruce or
Raymond Arroyo is here with this Friday
Follies segment where he's going to tell
us of how the funeral of a music legend
at times became a political rally plus
we got updates about NFL players
kneeling during the anthem and president
Trump's efforts to remake the NAFTA
agreement all coming up but first our
top story
CNN caught red-handed as we've been
telling you this week CNN's blockbusters
story last month about Michael Cohen was
dead wrong the network went wild with an
anonymously source report that claimed
Cohen was prepared to tell Muller's team
that President Trump knew in advance
about that infamous 2016 Trump Tower
meeting between Donald Trump jr. and a
Russian lawyer we now know that CNN lied
about Cohen's attorney Lanny Davis being
a source for the peace and here's a
kicker Davis now says the story is false
but still CNN is sticking with its story
and Business Insider is reporting that
the network isn't planning on revealing
its alleged second source oh and the
left wonders why Trump's fake news
narrative is working joining me now for
reaction is the Federalist Molly
Hemingway who's also a Fox News
contributor Howie Kurtz host of Fox
News's media buzz which airs at 11:00
a.m. on Sundays and dinesh d'souza
filmmaker whose new film death of a
nation is in theaters now and will be in
a special showing all weekend long
over Labor Day Dinesh let's start with
you here this is wild I mean CNN is you
know this is CNN the James Earl Jones
booming voice and it at one time like
back in the 80s when CNN started it was
considered kind of a gold standard of
this new type of journalism where does
it stand now after this Lanny Davis
story a complete bungle by the network
well one can almost think back
nostalgically to the 80s when CNN would
have shows like crossfire where they
would have a liberal a conservative Pat
Buchanan on one side Michael Kinsley on
the other that's not the CNN of today
now it's one thing to spin the news and
interpret it in a manner that is
consistent with your own ideological
agenda it's a completely different thing
to have a story in which you are
reporting facts the facts are exposed as
false and you dig your heels in and say
that they're true anyway I mean this is
taking fake news to a new level and it
is setting you may say almost a new
standard of deception that I think will
haunt CNN for a while yeah dinner movies
death of a nation this is like death of
journalism Howie Kurtz I know all the
cables compete with each other and it
can be pretty rough and tumble and one
side critic I get that but this is
unbelievable they claimed that they
tried to what contact Lanny Davis
initially with the story and that he
declined to comment but it turns out he
was initially the source for the story I
mean this story gets worse and worse the
more people marinate on it
yeah well Lanny Davis has told me that
he never confirmed this allegation for
CNN and he's sort of outed himself as a
source look CNN is trying to defend the
indefensible it will not discuss on the
air will not discuss publicly what went
wrong with the story about what Michael
Cole knew that Milan kong's lawyer now
says it's not true and this one sentence
we stand by our story stuff isn't
working because the network is accusing
the president of lying about his
knowledge about that Trump town meeting
I'll tell you one other thing Laura if
the White House had done something like
this thrown out and then send the air
then stand by it as the story began to
crumble CNN and lots of other news
organizations would be hammering the
place for stonewalling Molly and it's
not just how they're stonewalling
tonight it's how damaging the particular
allegation was that they ran with
apparently with some source they said
was lanny davis which ended up kind of
not being lanny davis so it's the
underlying allegation about that trump
tower meeting which we know would have
been at the crux of a muller
investigation well they claimed it was a
bombshell when they first reported this
story and as the story is falling apart
I think part of the reason why they're
unable to take responsibility for
flubbing the story is that they hyped it
so much but it's really part of a
pattern of behavior for CNN as it
relates to the Russia collusion
conspiracy theory that they have been
pushing for a year and a half and there
have been other stories that they
claimed had multiple anonymous sources
that also fell through you would
remember that they claimed that Don jr.
had advanced knowledge of a WikiLeaks
dump
well they claimed they had multiple
sources it turned out not to be true and
they never explained how their multiple
sources got it wrong they also claimed
that James Comey would contradict Donald
Trump's testimony about how James Comey
had told him three times he wasn't under
investigation well we all saw that
testimony he admitted that he had told
President Trump that three times just as
president Trump said they never
explained how they got that wrong and
those are just three examples of many
stories that they've gotten wrong about
the Russia could collusion theory now
damascena is not the only network under
fire for watching a huge story getting
it wrong but according to now new
reports the top brass at NBC tried to
put the kibosh on ronan pharaoh's
bombshell real bombshell story about
Harvey Weinstein sexual predation
basically forcing Ronan Farrow to take
the story to the New Yorker magazine
where everybody knows by now he
ultimately won a Pulitzer Prize and and
tonight rumors are also swirling that
NBC News Chairman Andy lack is on the
hot seat and this was after President
Trump weighed in on NBC's troubles last
night
lines from NBC which is probably worse
than CNN
[Applause]
but the word is they're firing the head
of NBC what a great thing to do how
smart
Denisha this is unreal everyone seen at
11:00 hour I think if the if the CNN
story was a lie of commission the NBC
story is a lie of omission now just
think about how powerful their ideology
would have to be because remember this
is actually not a lie that would have
helped Trump this actually is a lie to
cover up a principle the principle of
sexual harassment the principle of
sexual abuse which is actually a
principle on the left and so essentially
this principle can only be trumped by a
greater principle on the left and the
greater principle on the left here is we
have to protect our own team they're
very powerful people on the Left George
Soros Harvey Weinstein and it is an
unwritten rule in a sense of progressive
journalism that these people are
untouchable and that you have to run
defense for them and run protection for
them I believe that was what was going
on at NBC yeah he thought he was
untouchable and my Harvey Weinstein
thought everyone else was touchable
that's the that's the problem here Howie
Kurtz this is another wild story a
Harvey Weinstein had an enormous amount
of influence at Hollywood enormous
amount of political clout with all the
fund raisers he hosted the money he
raised in deep friendships within the
peacock I mean he and Andy lack I hear
were very good friends what happened to
the we treat all women the same as men
we believed in women's rights and when
this Ronan Farrow young journalist
hadn't was hot on the trail of this
story general counsel was saying you
better back off or we're gonna smear you
again these are reported allegations by
I guess the producer of Pharos work
right well that particular allegation is
denied by NBC and I don't know how much
pressure weinstein brought to bear but
it remains a huge embarrassment for mbc
that after eight months of research that
let ronan far walk out the door with
that prize-winning story that
essentially launch the me2 movement and
now you have hours investigative report
producer excuse me who just left NBC
saying this was a massive breach of
journalistic integrity by NBC that NBC
was never enthusiastic about the story
NBC claims he didn't have enough and
everybody willing to go on camera but
two months later this meticulously
reported piece appears in The New Yorker
and it looked like NBC just didn't have
the guts to take on Harvey Weinstein
what's your gut on this Howie do you
think you think this producer is blowing
smoke here I mean it sounds it sounds a
little odd to me doesn't it like they go
we didn't have enough they said today he
didn't have enough sources it wasn't
well sourced enough I think he was
working on it and they came down and
said when you're a reporter you know
whether your bosses are enthusiastic
particularly about a sensitive
investigative piece NBC was not NBC was
willing to let him walk out the door and
so exactly nothing can change the fact
that NBC blew this one big-time and
Molly before before we let you go this
story also bled into Andrew Cuomo
because the report came out that he
pulled back on an investigation into
Weinstein I guess after what Weinstein's
attorney gave a $25,000 donation so it
it even bleeds into that part of the
political world it's really clear that
we see a lot of stories that get
suppressed or elevated depending on
political affiliations or friendships
and that's really inappropriate we want
to believe that our legal institutions
and our media institutions will tell the
story regardless of where it takes them
or apply justice regardless and that is
a problem that we're facing in this
country right now with different
standards for different people all right
we have one more topic we have time for
that one final topic president Trump
last night also shared his thoughts on
the current censorship controversy with
big tech look at social media to think
old free speech rights you look at
Google Facebook Twitter and other social
media giants and I've made it clear that
we as a country cannot tolerate
political censorship blacklisting and
rigged search results and you know it
can go the other way
also we will not let large corporation
silence conservative voices well the
focus on this from President Trump and
conservatives may be having an effect
with reports like this one from the New
York Times stating that some Facebook
employees are fighting against this
intolerant liberal culture Dinesh you
have written about this and books and
spoken about this on college campus
campuses the West Coast otherwise
affectionately known as the Left Coast
especially in big tech overwhelmingly
left-wing overwhelmingly probably voted
for Hillary and yet they say oh this is
just an algorithm you're all you're all
floating conspiracy theories but now you
got Facebook employees complaining about
the monoculture this I think is very
scary so many conservatives fled to
social media to escape the bias of the
mainstream media and now to discover
this effort to sort of take people and
make them into digital non persons I
mean one has to go back to Aldous Huxley
or George Orwell to find out this kind
of stuff going on now a lot of people
say well gee these are private companies
they should be able to do whatever they
want but this is actually not true if
Google or Facebook decided for example
we're going to shadow ban blacks or
we're going to shadow banned Latinos
these companies would be shut down
overnight they know that they can't do
that and they wouldn't even dare but
apparently with conservatives they feel
that it's okay to have political
discrimination even though I don't see
fundamentally the difference here
between say political discrimination and
discrimination on any other basis how
how big of an issue is this I mean I
can't on my radio audience it blows up
the lines everyone wants to talk about
it everyone seems to have an experience
with it and I know that seems anecdotal
but I find Bing by the way being is the
best search engine there's the least
bias in Bing for whatever reason that's
what I've discovered Howie
right well it's a huge issue because
social media is the new public square
and Facebook and Twitter both have
acknowledged that they have a problem
with instances of bias against
conservatives I think the evidence
against
is a little less clear so President
Trump and others on the right are
obviously going to speak out about this
because if you don't you know you can
disappear if you don't show up in the
search rankings or in the trending
topics or whatever but the same time I
don't think government regulation is the
answer so there has to be another way
now Molly we talked about this earlier
that there's a thought that given the
enormity of these corporations and is
how we said internet porn it out this is
the public square today this is what the
equivalent of what you know we used to
see in the old town square with people
with a bullhorn and so could could there
be a movement to treat them more like
public utilities so they have some quasi
you know government oversight of these
entities or that would that open up a
total can of worms
perhaps in the other direction at some
point I personally am NOT a fan of
regulation as an answer to this
situation
but these companies absolutely have
sometimes huge market share percentage
of which would make Standard Oil blush
they are cognizant that they are going
to make the government want to weigh in
just because though they're not
governmental entities does not mean that
they aren't threats to free expression
in the same way that people get mad when
President Trump criticizes the media
because they claim that that's not a
threat to free expression it's also a
threat when big tech is telling people
what they can and can't say all right
guys thank you so much